hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play dishonored
alright ooh rat skewers my baby alright
let's get going I know I missed some
stuff like a safe but I could ha ha ha
Oh see that's right
I totes forgot how to play yeah yeah
thank you
hey hey the house how oh there's two of
you yeah I remember how to play
nope uh-huh what up yes yeah I'm not
exactly sure what happened or how it
happened from five feet away but I am
awesome
absolutely love me in all that I do
Oh more rescues hey you look tasty you
too oh you obliterate it I'm so strong
hahahahaha grip I need to meet Samuel
and once I do I'm gonna give him a piece
of my mind or who's that
no wait that's the guy that helped me
I'll go give him something else like a
hug or something
attention all right then the assassin
uh-huh that's me I don't think that's me
disappearance of Lady Emily heir to the
throne as temporarily escaping state
come not yeah over here uh-huh
uh hello I'm a friend uh I'm Samuel no
no if I trust you I work for some good
people who want very much to meet you
right they said you'd come out here
I could still hardly believe it uh-huh
I'll take you to meet them just down the
river from here whatever you say man
need a moment first no let's go it's
remind me right there that all reminded
me of that the thing from overall chaos
oh that's probably not good I should
probably keep the chaos to a minimum
yeah probably
all right by the way continue yeah that
all reminded me of um half-life 2 that
the the tech demo thing that they had
going on the Islander the Fisherman's
Wharf or the port I don't remember what
it was called yeah it's all very
reminiscent oh man that's gorgeous
this is the Hound pits pub closed for
business after district marked office
dead from play man I just love all of
this
he don't know what face phenomenal I
love games that have rich environments
it's like a frickin movie set some games
have more than a result so the watch
will break in with sword strong huh and
now that you've escaped there the Lord
Regent is going to be tearing the city
apart gotcha
looks like it's already a bit
ramshackled you know if you know what I
mean me I don't have like the rest of
the boys
the Admirals a man to be reckoned with
right if anyone can help you find that
missing girl lady Emily and clear your
name he can the Admiral I thought that
was one Admiral that was trying to kill
me I don't know I can't tell with all
these fancy titles the Hound pits pub
pitched achievement unlocked yeah I like
about uh what's all this then I should
probably shouldn't be exploring at ah
get on get tall get to it ha ha what's
eating me run now look at it hmm
god damn you I am angry if that happened
huh try to eat me out if I expect
they're hard at work in there of what us
join them it'll help you again whoever
really killed the Empress right okay now
now no yeah I don't mind if I borrowed
in dude secret loyalists missing you
this later Lord Pendleton the man of the
hour
hello uh goes I'm gonna call you
forehead nama call you five head him
like I call you stubby until the Lord
Regent purred
those of us who wouldn't recognize his
claim with okay stubby and I'm Lord chef
opinion ah five herb is it the nobility
in our little group uh huh
but we all act as equals here the Hound
Pittsburgh right sure we do momentous
occasion uh-huh I'm going to come out
with we've been building a coalition of
loyalists aimed at ending the lord
regions cheering really study from thank
you risk of execution we're committed to
finding young lady Emily uh and seeing
her crowned as Empress that's a great
idea five head but we can't do any of it
without you uh-huh we need your skills
yeah your ability to fight uh-huh and in
helping us really we're going to help
you destroy the men who murdered Ian
that's awesome
you must be so I'm not we can discuss
this further after you throw you five
and I want to discuss it right now
should introduce yourself to Pierre he's
challenging at times
hmm but his industrious mind buys in
that right right whatever or you yes
finish Piero's as much an art aquarium
in transmission he's going to be
crafting the gear you'll need uh-huh go
talk to him and then get some sleep what
gear do I need ha sides wrist okay the
mission clues once I got bureaus an
inventor who is available to craft an
upgrade equipment I like it
Samuel is the boat man has smuggled you
I got it No so now I need to find
Pierrot no who's that huh mystery people
hello Hiro
uh-huh all custom work for you I will
create tools master okay creepy
No
the tank of whale oil whale oil will you
get a new tank from upstairs please
while I hold this in place be careful
wow I'm not gonna read that you guys can
pause and skim through this if you'd
like this looks just like a newspaper
clipping just environmental fluff when
it explodes there's a parable whale oil
is unstable no I'll not sign off on
these purchases are back a part of
crystals here be more Academy footing
the bill okay so the creepy guy over
here can't get what he wants I think
that was a letter from five head or
stubby I'm not sure I think stubby
whales in the section who hauled oh and
then they just took her up cut into the
mass of tentacles around her mouth what
huh what uh oh okay oh they're talking
about filter feeder whales Oh whale oil
processing wow this is all very
intriguing oh man
slicing off the fattiest parts while
they still live hemlock essence
hahaha oh wait no was I supposed to
always refill in no way what
oh no I wasn't yeah this doesn't look
like any whale oil than I remember
what whatevs it's up now plug it tell me
what to do
did it cuz I wanted to do it just
perfect it's my man thank you
here see uh-huh assassins men
right you're a wanted man so everyone in
the city knows your face okay you just
hold still fit mosquito size there can
you see normal Oh
lens out of the line there I don't know
I could create more upgrades for your
gear weapons munitions for our situation
who's desperate
please Gavin the city for value that's
it I will sell them on the black market
that should give us the money to crap
the things you need for why tell me what
oh I just have a love Pierrot a sleep
bolt oh okay I guess I should take a
more peaceful routes I'll go for sleep
bolts in a rewire tool disable security
devices to make them work in your favor
by using a rewire tool on the 30 problem
for the security device you want to hack
revived walls with knives are kind
pylons Watchtower LeBrons good riddle
all right we're good thank you creepy
No I advise gets us
I'm not tired I don't get even more
difficult you should rest
I don't see why everyone thinking that
I'm so tired I'm gonna look around shut
up
no I do let me know if you need anything
not from you let me out of here alright
so um I think I'm gonna go take a nap or
something that corvo's bed that's my bed
that's me that person that is me ah mine
uh see any money here has a mine um
climb up here good I'm up here now this
is good I like this um how about this is
mine gonna be and empty mine and mine
you've met Piero go ahead don't want to
get some rest then alright how do I
holster my stuff I forget I got to pick
up something or I don't know there's
probably a button don't tell me what to
do I know what I'm doing huh mine yeah
ah come on still don't mind me yes very
much so your hand interfere
oh hello user say you need of course he
did people are foolish and believe
whatever they're told
yeah okay we had more trust him no one
talking about me talking about me
total hi hello there the Admiral served
in the Navy under the Empress uh-huh but
something happened with the Lord Regent
that drove the Admiral out huh if I
understand it right okay how baby
Admiral Havelock made it very clear that
we aren't to carry lamps outside okay
that's nice all right your boy me who
are you please follow me to York well I
don't need to follow you I know where
I'm going and apparently since everyone
wants me to sleep I guess I should sleep
oh this is crap
I'll go to sleep now collect fellow
never mind
somewhere else
I like this I like this game aloud I get
the feeling that it's gonna be more
free-roaming pretty soon oh hello octa
hell oh I see how this is I'm going
crazy I have officially lost my mind but
Wow we shall we have a legend now cool
the graphics and art style of this game
art have I mentioned that cuz it is
awesome actually this scene like framing
right here reminds me of I thought a
whale woohoo
reminds me of home world actually which
is weird and I'm like God I'm nerding
out geeking out about everything hello I
uh I know a life has taken a turn has it
nom the Empress is dead the precious
daughter emily is lost somewhere pity
and you will play a pivotal role in the
days to come for this I have chosen you
and drawn you into the void um no I am
the outsider and this is my mark
ah voices in the world in the unaffected
great forces that I recall magic now
these forces will slow your bed why use
this newfound power my gift to you why
would you just give me this but of
Columbia I will not faithful press
right-mouse to execute a fat and
stealthy forward dash with the world you
can use it to move upward but the
distance is reduced aiming at lettuce
will allow you to blink forward and
climb up alright so
Oh quick oh no you cannot save her you
cannot save her you cannot save her okay
yeah that's so sad she was my lady well
I don't know if she's my lady do you
hide about my lady oh oh oh oh the heck
is this who are you and who are you also
why do you look like that guy douches
your twin douches you're the you're the
you're the tweeze Yeah right
that is a whale a quiet spear well oh
because of the whale oil
that's so weird why is whale oil like
the power for everything and everything
just so colorful and live lag oh wait no
oh that was a chess back there hey I
gotta go back Boop haha okay oh there we
go
haha no need to panic uh probably some
of you were screaming screaming at me
that a [ __ ] I was young oh man I'm so
tired
alright there was a chess here that I
did not open ah wait no that's it that's
stupid
okay so if you right-click it
automatically takes a potion and if
you're patient your mana will rejuvenate
to the point where you dis pent it but
if you try to double use it it won't
rejuvenate as much that's my
understanding and if I'm patient
I get over here a bit of a challenge
hello
oh are you that the other douche you are
the other douche oh yeah I remember you
climb it up on your table what are you
thinking in me aria
yeah what are those things wow those
walkers Striders those are Striders no
no way they're people riding him oh
they're gonna die man I did think that a
lot of the things in this game reminded
me of half-life 2 like the architecture
here looks like the Citadel architecture
and these are very like Striders so but
that's cool anyway I don't really care
ok up Wow what's this nothing fish all
right
not asking questions not asking
questions and we got here
OOP ha ha
how excuse me ha boom hey there was
chest hair
here's that follow your trial girl I'll
give you great trials seasons bearing my
mark in lonely places of your world and
at shrines raised in mine right great
powers beyond those of other men wrong
to help you find these rooms by giving
this the heart of a living thing molded
by my why would I want that
pleasing some no mini secret no no God
no no no matter how they may be you're
gonna take my heart out on Jamie listen
to the heart now and find another you
gonna take my heart out oh why am i oh
why am i holding is equipping the heart
in your left hand helps you locate bone
charms or runes even through walls the
heart beats light up when you're facing
a bone charm or rune and it beats faster
as you get close the heart will whisper
secrets if you press right wall
targeting a person or location
this is the end of all things
okie-dokie thank you hard
y-you mean the Stars
creative
sound good or actually no I'll keep you
safe from the doom baby yeah early age
uh-huh okay I'm supposed to drop down
there this is the end of all things
okay you said that already
you're boring me now lady whoa I thought
it was like some fat bloated dead corpse
floating here come on I've been playing
a lot of horror games don't look at me
like that you could see the mistake that
I would make there oh I know
ooh there it is okay seven uh-huh
and then I go I come on okay that's not
it I'm gonna I'm gonna poop it maybe if
I get up on this bow oh yeah that's
totes it and then I get up mom and then
I get up on that one too right y'all
right right a fish okay that's
apparently not it okay that's some fat
but what oh oh how do I get there wait
do I fall through here oh yes okay
there's obviously I'm an idiot
I'm an idiot maybe there was a secret up
there maybe I could have gotten up there
but I don't know let's just carry on oh
no not at all
look flush and waiting people knew how
ornate and Purdy's yeah was that oh okay
this looks good right once you've
collected some runes open the journal
and go to the power section to exchange
them for powers interesting dark vision
possession then time devouring so wow
these are all awesome ooh what and him
unaware enemies who don't see you turn
to ash as they die
that would be so great for my chaos and
everything turns to chaos I'm an agent
of chaos alright um help that would be
awesome for like stealth yes killing
people on the go I guess I could just
put him to sleep but that's for losers
let's see here
ah the bomb I'm going to use it for now
let's do this for Z seems like the most
useful dark vision
oh no that costs mana this is like a no
mana thing I kind of want it I can't get
it oh I get it
oh I get it nevermind
go dark vision alright this will be good
anyway because it's very useful for this
stuff because I don't want to be quite
as rambunctious in hello what I have
given you falls upon you yeah as it has
to the others before okay now I return
you to your world okay but know that I
will be watching with great interest
been phenomenal okay
this is excellent drop acid nasty
assassin hidden in the old bar on the
river your new allies plans have plans
to share with you me with the loyalists
in a circle to lure learn what they've
got in mind I can't read I can't read
talk words and stuff
I have the mark let's see the golden cat
the finest ladies in all the Isles yeah
does he look familiar right why where
does this go the poop oh that is so
freakin gorgeous everything about this
game is just so gorgeous I can't get
over it it's incredible I mean the color
scheme is bright luminescent is this
where is this a few dress excerpt from a
book it's a bit too much to read so
pause and read if you'd like yeah I
don't want to take up so much time
reading because otherwise I'd be reading
for hours on end
call the spheres and this playthrough is
gonna be like an unending play pretty
but where does that go OOP ow my ankles
I spilled blood all over that okay I
don't know where that I don't think that
got me anywhere all right let's get back
to the bar ooh there's something there
do I still my thank you
Oh blue yeah
no one saw anything you didn't see
anything buddy hello Piero oh no wait
this is wrong
goodnight I like jump out your balcony
here I like it there's so many places
you can creepy crawl and just go around
are anyway let's go in here
oh that pile of wood out there it's a
hole are you so ladies ha ha ha oh hello
it's the maid I remember you from before
I had a sailor for a boyfriend once oh
he thought he'd strike gold digging in
the pan dision cliffs they found his
ship drifting him so you single that is
that we say aye to attend services
whatever so uh they've just gotten more
and more I don't know oh seven
structures or witchcraft
yeah what's crafted so so nonsensical
totally illegitimate well let's get down
to it hey stop it
first off I know that assassination is
darkness
right sure it is sometimes good men have
to do bad things to make the world right
our purpose is clear we want to restore
Her Majesty's line by finding and put it
in the called window yeah to those ends
we'll high acting shadow sounds good to
take them apart piece by I like that
my sadistic side says yes oversee your
camel dies by your hand it won't be easy
he's protected by his overseers an army
of religious ah huh but if anyone can do
I can your exploits or lesser are what
if I Dynamo carries a private journey
once you've eliminated him get the
Johanna because we think it contains
Emily location recovering hers obviously
critical assuming she's alive I bet you
just remember our cause and structure
huh we're counting on you why should I
trust you at all Campbell is holding a
former overseer by the name of Martin
he's one of us and if you manage to find
him give him whatever help you can okay
he's a master strategist and he got
caught working for our cause uh-huh it'd
be good to have him back here the help
it's okay whatever Hound pits oh hello
baby
haha hi there Harv oh hello hi I'm
Calista I can list it I work here for
Admiral Havelock do you I'm sorry to
intrude on your business but this is
important
I suspect you're going to kill the high
overseer I sure AM
that wretched yep there's really no
reason for you to listen to me but my
uncle Jeff colonel serves as captain in
the city y-yeah but he's a good man
maybe only family the chatter and
servant circles is that Campbell just
took delivery of an exotic poison and I
think I know why my uncle's not
corruptable like the rest of them right
Campbell is going to poison my uncle do
you think you could protect but be able
to you used to do that right before you
had your current profession hey before
you became Ennis hey that sounds like
judging yes maybe I won't help you
maybe oh I'll help you baby I help you
I've totally forgotten your name but
I'll help you Chris Chris Tanev all
goose kantham Chrissy I'll call you
Chrissy head out let's go just wondering
sir if you thought about perhaps seeing
Pierrot before venture oh okay
stop yelling at me I'll help maybe hi
baby what you looking at huh that's so
interesting how that ceiling is hero PR
Oh Pierre what can I do for you I wanna
buy some you stupid all right
upgrades oh yeah i crap I'm out of money
I just had to buy all those poison darts
flab tastic
ah perfect Oh 20 coins oh yeah yeah
gimme what can I do you can upgrade my
crap upgrade it the Wow
yeah crossbow accuracy oh yeah mask
optics oh yeah
bone terms capacity does that mean how
did you know about my bone charms it's
by an ami who I need bolt capacity
I like the crossbow better than the gun
anyways it's a stealthier option so I
want more bolts definitely ooh
no just books oh god you're such a nerd
pierre calc ah make me so angry fear I
can't even stare that it's so beautiful
all right let's gotta go just give this
are giving you the signal to the
Distillery District oh hello I know I
guess that's going on oh man I just love
the environment high overseer Campbell
leads the city's militant religious
factions and is a close allied to the
Lord region Campbell is completely
corrupt and holds the secret to Emily's
location infiltrate the office of the
high overseer steal Campbell's Journal
and eliminate him and allied to the
loyalists Martin is being held there
free him alone to escape and I got to
protect that lady's uncle
oh that totally looks like city 17 used
to be go straight up clamors Boulevard
the van I was not so visa half the
city's dead to play the other half
fighting over what's left right
city watch still holds the bigger
streets and they set up those wall life
checkpoints man walks through one of
those and ends up burned to a crisp
writes everything not controlled by the
city watch is gang turn huh huh are the
real life birds living on the fringes
like that Greg Greg
I say she's not probably
worse just take your pick okay I'll
figure it out
I'm I am a Master Assassin okay now I
have two tasks okay optional spare
captain Colonel I want to do that
because I I want to I want to get in
good with this lady there I ensure
captain Colonel survives visit
that's gonna be my major one okay all
right
escape that's here mine Yahoo are you
gonna eat that
uh sorry I needed it force us to cookies
this so much detail I can't take it
it doesn't look so good oh by the way I
have to mention that I said bethesda
made this game it's actually Arkane
studios bethesda was just a publisher so
they're dumping bodies I'm huffing whoa
whoa Oh
last one was moving what yeah the little
one oh not possible I inspected them
myself
keep working okay so that's bad moving
no more ow
you're lucky I don't [ __ ] I really I'm
gonna try to be a bit more stealthy I do
like the Stallions I do I mean the first
time I played through Skyrim whose whose
all stuff boo hello who are you
not even stupid cut yeah oh you're not
leaving yes you are
ha baby give me one uh take that you
didn't see a thing lady he didn't see a
thing
stupid report all my crap oops I shot it
was for good moral sleeping Darden then
I stabbed him I'm an idiot I forgot
which one was um the correct one okay
anyway so let's go my bad my mistake
okay so I need to get to the dunwall
distillery and number three interesting
Oh God I love it free roaming adventures
I love killing whale oil and Clemmie Oh
ruin or bone charm nearby ah there it is
okay I got it
ooh this more holy crap there's all
sorts of stuff
garbage garbage garbage got what are you
doing lady hey are you that crazy granny
you are a 10 yeah how do I get that yes
yep creepy creepy granny all right how
do we get over there I'll see a root um
nope okay I do not see a root unless I
climb up let's climb up give me lady
don't mind me just sneaking into your
house one second I gotta save cuz I
haven't saved in awhile actually don't
know what the quick save button is if
there is one at five six
I see it I just don't know how to get
lady I will be with you in just a moment
you don't see a thing
you don't see a thing lady Oh didn't see
a thing Oh super still master fastened
best there ever was yeah oh yeah yeah oh
hello
be careful Gordo they called her granny
Ram yeah
I wouldn't recognize her real name or
even the name of her family huh but an
emperor begged for her hand once and
rich young men fought each other for her
favor uh-huh
I watched her consider them all measure
their Worth and find them one well she
made the wrong choices then didn't she
then she made a different trevor it was
wrong you're on your way to face the
high overseer the leader of a greatcoat
dedicated to loathing me loading you
what will you do I wonder why loathing
you I don't trust you at all I don't
care if you gave me these gifts I don't
trust you and yes I am going over 30
minutes I'm gonna make all the AB the
episodes 45 minutes low why because I
can you I'm gonna steal all your stuff
green oh come on why did I just take up
an urn who sleep darts hey Co thank you
lady oh there we go
thank you granny you're the bad huh huh
oh no I'm not good oh no you don't see
your faint grating I said oh yeah sure
they are I'll be there
he's creepy well I got a check for YES
on everyone all right I'm a tiger he'll
send us food not not bullets okay and
one more all right
yeah I am moving into a 45 minutes long
because as with most of my non horse
stuff I don't want to drag out for weeks
and weeks I want to give you guys the
content the playthrough as much as
possible so that's what I want also I
like to play the game so I won't play it
longer here I like this game was this as
if this would just be sitting out in the
middle of the road attention Watchmen
this district is now considered a highly
infected area residents are to be
escorted to adjacent neighborhoods Oh
delivered for immediate deportation to
the flooded district remain in position
until 12 I'd personnel have completed
the remove uh-huh
I can take out the power climb up the
crates and use the roof I'll take out
the power just in case any day I did it
body but I'll still climb up like a
mouse Master Assassin boughs lakum vows
and mastered vows assassin well these
things doesn't last long enough uh
burial
like this oh man when I first saw the
cinematic trailer for this game I was
looking for this roof climbing stuff uh
I can that way I can do this this house
Oh aren't I gonna get the plague just
hanging around all these guys timeless
children's rhymes okay I would read this
but I don't have the time to read
everything probably me touching these
books is getting me all sorts of
infected so pause the video if you'd
like to read those Thank You Lucy blah
blah blah blah blah bluh blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah maybe
maybe after I finished my let's play
I'll actually do a playthrough this and
really really take the time to see
bottle street
or bottle Street Oh bottle street boys I
can read this is yes yes Oh Holly crap
there's all sorts of stuff when you just
walking around jeez yes I just took all
of this gangs earnings and everything
they ever had I love it
I love a free roam exploring I am a
Master Assassin I gotta get to that
objective it's so cool every inch of the
city is loveling with lovingly that
inner tongue really oh it's just so
gorgeous
okay what's up poop Oh can't get in
there ah what's the point then ice made
a big circle and I got good for there
interesting
I know Oh Oh what did I do
no no one saw me
gotcha now no stop it ow oh crap
no no no don't be a hero oh I screwed up
nope Oh your gang members I see oops
um you didn't see a crap I screwed up
whoa where are you ah this is a bad idea
but isn't it I got an achievement though
I think oh here we go it's stupid you
daughter oh I suppose I was able to find
what the hell huh the rats came in dupa
dupa dupa right then while they're being
mert alized I'm gonna go get this okay
keep banging my place thank you
conscious what we found a strange rune
on the woman who used to sell pastries
at the street not her sure how she died
but since this thing looks superstitious
we set it aside for the overseers after
shipping over take it for them to them
for disposable or whatever they do with
it don't forget that guy and the rats
were there I don't know why the rats
left bone charms are far away in output
apparently I got away from the people in
a really bad way but I did it y'all saw
I did it yeah so I did it
uh-huh yeah hip hip hip hip
bloob and go to home it maybe I should
get all the bone charms Han let me like
a save here just in case you guys yell
at me and say that I should you know how
it is flip go to Holy Ghost where all
that guy's so ugly right guy in the back
so ugly this guy in the front so ugly
mmm
no one can see anything I am like shadow
with a knight now you're the second
thing is when the skin really starts to
come all the way off is that true or is
it the itching that really gets you or
the rats
Jasper isn't it's not so bad in here
except I miss your wife huh let's see
huh
you don't scare me Macbeth sniff thank
you Oh ease that's just a hologram or
something
what a sight you are oh no it's not good
I know who you are and what you're here
to do and I can help back up
unlock me and I'll buy you a drink in a
couple of days by the void I'll buy you
a hundred drinks OOP
there you go congratulations buddy you
are as good to stand up straight thank
you Kovalev welcome Martin what you're
here to do tonight is of the highest
importance we've got to find Emily so
kill Campbell and make it I have to save
this ladies um search his body for the
Jonah his notorious black uh-huh and get
out okay Campbell is right with the
gardening current Kurt ow and word from
my informant is that Campbell is going
to poison him maybe you can use that to
your advantage
Curnow is that guy was supposed to say I
won't be of any help here matee I make
my own way back to the Hound pits bub if
I see Samuel the boat man I'll tell him
to pick you up in the backyard uh-huh
behind the office of the high Overson
okay you know the spirits guide you in
their enemies head hit the floor without
you taking a scratch right oh is that
what I look like
yeah well I guess I got that dark
mysterious look going on shaggy unshaven
beard and all that yeah yeah I suppose
I'm devilishly handsome
I suppose so alright let's see what's
going on here
now I need to ok he's meeting ok he's
meeting with him in
so that's our
come on lemme up let me up art climb oh
well never mind
OOP pop hip ah my blink when you can
climb what if there's like a third
person hug you guys heretics Brad
it sounds pain have you ever seen the
rich ooh I've never seen the heretics
Brad used no it's a rare occurrence
uh-huh
but I did spy the face of one so I am
being stealthy hey hey wait I'll keep
away you rats
dirty dirty rats all right whoa stealthy
never like a shadow I will like a silent
fart get it silent
get it nothing like a good party
ha did not mean to do that hello no how
is useless lack of boughs fronds trees
alleys yes I could run through
everything and kill everybody but what's
the fun in that
huh can I get up there even
ow ow ow ow ow ow-ow-ow
okay that was dumb of me out really dumb
I did dumb things there I was dumb
haha come on come on oh wow Walsh
alright I'm out of time anyway
Oh ah so cheap and you ripped me off I
was totally doing fine up until then
yeah totally so anyway thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
form videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye